[Music]
for several years now you've been
playing a high school kid yeah but you
yourself in real life didn't enjoy
school is that right well not so much I
didn't really like the the structured
studies you know I always I always had a
passion for learning as a kid but I
never really liked school so much right
so what would you do when you see it a
passion for learning but you didn't like
school would you try and find stuff out
on your own would you go on the internet
what would you do well before I mean I'm
dating myself now but when I was a kid
it's already very happy far before them
sorry come on do it someone else will
before the advent of the internet I my
mom had a set of those the World Book
Encyclopedia yeah we had those growing
up you know this way yeah and I would go
yeah anything you need to know yes yes
and see had its own volume and I would
go to the show please what Oh cuz
there's so much information understate
anyhow I would go to the shelf and I'd
get one of these books after my mom she
sent me to bed go to bed and I okay I'm
gonna bed and I would get the flashlight
and I would go to the shelf and I'd get
the world book and I'd sneak it back in
my room and I would hide under the
covers and I'd read the world book what
you'd read the Encyclopedia yeah under
the covers that section I mean I think
of all the things you could be caught
doing
[Laughter]
it's just it's like Lapidus mom reading
about precipitation what did you I mean
do you have a good memory of stuff that
you has it served you well do you know
stuff from the encyclopedia no yeah no
absolutely all types of random
information like give me an example of
let's bust out something for me that
that's downloaded that you still have to
this day from the encyclopedia I could
tell you all about wastewater treatment
plants go for it okay well you know
there's three stages of treatment
depending on you know how complicated
the treatment plan is is primary and
secondary and tertiary and the primary
treatment removes all the solids the
secondary treatment we don't have the
technology to make me fade out
we don't know that's crazy that's the
kind of stuff you're under the covers
reading about waste management yeah yeah
and and like state capital stuff like
that none of which I think I remember
any some stuff I retain sometimes stuff
I didn't well the important thing is you
were learning yes about waste what
happens when you flush the toilet yeah